INTRO:
Ever since the pandemic started and Jerome
Powell started the money printer, the stock market
has only gone one direction up. This has trained
millions of retail investors who started investing
during the pandemic to constantly buy the dip.
If a stock sells of 3 to 5% it’s time to buy and
if a stock sells off 10% it’s time to go all in.
Ironically, when people buy these quote-on-quote
discounts, they’re simply investing at all-time
high levels from a few days or weeks ago. So,
it’s not like they’re really getting a discount,
but we can’t really blame them because this is
all they’ve seen. In fact, throughout all of 2021,
the S&P 500 didn’t even experience a single 10%
correction. The largest sell-off the index saw
last year wasn’t even 6%. So, it makes sense
that many retail investors have been trained
to go all-in on even the slightest of pullbacks.
Many are even claiming that this is simply the
new normal and that we’ll never see another
40 or 50% correction in the stock market. But
this is actually the most dangerous sentiment to
have because the tops of bubbles are literally
called the “New Paradigm!!”. So, here’s the
truth about stocks that don’t come back.
THE DISRUPTORS:
Starting off the list, we have the innovative
companies or the growth companies that have
dominated the market over the past 2 years. Often,
these companies promise to revolutionize how we
do everyday tasks. For example, instead
of building up a strong network of taxis
that’s easily accessible, these companies will
promise to provide you with self-driving cars.
Or instead of building more stores and carrying
more inventory close to where you live, they’ll
promise to deliver any product straight to your
doorstep. Generally, these companies have the best
of intentions, but they don’t have the best of
balance sheets, so it just takes a simple market
downturn to wipe them out completely. Take Mark
Cuban’s Broadcast.com for example. In the 1990s,
Broadcast.com allowed users to stream audio and
eventually even video through the internet. Given
that most of us spend hours streaming podcasts,
music, videos, and movies today, this was clearly
a great idea. And multiple hundred billion dollar
companies have been built based on just streaming
one or two types of media. Yahoo could see this
future in 1999, and that’s why they agreed to buy
Broadcast.com for $5.7 billion. But, even Yahoo
couldn’t sustain the company through the dotcom
crash, and they ended up shutting down one sector
after another until they shut down the entire
company. Another big bust from the dotcom era is
Pets.com. The idea of Pets.com was simple: sell
pet toys and food through the internet to make
these products more accessible and convenient than
ever before. They had big investors on board like
Amazon who at one point owned half the company.
This allowed Pets.com to complete an extremely
successful IPO raising over $300 million.
Yet, just 268 days later, they went
bankrupt thanks to the dotcom crash.
Now, Pets.com wasn’t a bad idea by any means.
Chewy basically executed the same concept a
decade later and they’re worth nearly $20 billion
today. So, clearly, the idea doesn’t really matter
when we’re talking about a stock market crash.
The only thing that matters during a downturn is
the balance sheet because if a company can’t
survive the downturn, they’ll never actually
release they’re quote on quote “revolutionary
product or service”. And that’s just two examples.
52% of all DotCom companies went bankrupt by
2004, and there’s no doubt that that included
dozens of brilliant ideas. So, clearly, simply
investing in a company with a good idea doesn’t
guarantee investment growth. In fact, during
the dotcom bubble, most of the time it didn’t.
THE SURVIVORS:
Ok, so betting on unprofitable
disruptors is basically just a gamble. But what
if you’re not investing in the unprofitable
disruptors like Rivian, Lucid, Teledoc,
and Nanodimension. What if you’re investing
in profitable disruptors like Tesla, Shopify,
and Square. These companies will most likely
survive a multi-year bear market with no
additional funding. So, buying the dips
on these companies is relatively safe right?
Well, if you hold long enough, then probably,
but you’re also likely looking at several
painful years ahead. For example, take a
look at dotcom favorites that actually survived
and ended up becoming big. Before Amazon became
a trillion-dollar e-commerce giant and liberals
started hating Jeff Bezos, Amazon went through
the dotcom crash. And Amazon didn’t sell of 40
or 50 or even 70%. Amazon sold off a painful
95%. At that point, you’d probably be questioning
if the company is gonna survive regardless of how
the balance sheet looks. But, even if you stayed
invested, you would’ve had to wait 7 years just to
almost breakeven. And then, the 2008 financial
recession would hit, and you’d be down 70% on
your initial investment once again. It wasn’t till
November of 2009 or 10 years after the dot-com
peak that you would actually start making money on
Amazon. Another great example is Booking holdings.
Booking holdings was a travel booking company
that went hyperbolic during the dotcom bubble,
and it’s still around today and it’s doing better
than ever before. But like with all companies that
were founded during the dotcom bubble, it had to
go through the dotcom crash first. And this time,
we’re not even talking about a 95% crash, we’re
talking about a 99.36% crash. This means that
for every $100 you invested into Booking holdings,
you would have just 64 cents or not even a dollar
left at the bottom of the crash. And it took
Booking Holdings 14 years just to recover to its
dot-com peak. Also, it should be noted that even
today, while Booking Holdings is at $2000 a share,
that’s only a 2X from its dot-com peak meaning
that it took 25 years to just double your money.
Even just investing in the S&P 500 would’ve
given you a better return, not to mention,
you would’ve never been down 99.36%. So,
while you may not lose money if you go
all-in on a disruptor that survives, you could
easily be waiting a decade just to break even.
STUCK FOREVER:
Ok, so disruptors are dangerous. You’re could
either lose it all or you could end up waiting
several years just to breakeven. But, what if you
don’t even mess with disruptor or growth stocks.
What if you’re a blue-chip investor that only
invests in the largest and most stable companies
in the world like Apple, Microsoft, and Google?
Is it ok to go all-in on dips in this scenario?
Well, not really. In fact, I’d say this is worse
than going all-in on a profitable disruptor. With
profitable disruptors, you can be sure that if
the company is able to weather the downturn,
they’re probably going to the moon once the
market recovers. The same cannot be said about
slower-moving large-cap companies. Here’s the
thing, while we like to often complain about
companies being too powerful and having too
big of a monopoly, companies don’t stay at
their peak forever. In fact, if you’re gonna be
deterministic about anything in the stock market,
it should be that companies come and go. And
with the rise of technology and rapid disruption,
the lifespans of companies are getting shorter and
shorter. In fact, Mckinsey & Company found that
the average time a company stays in the S&P 500 is
just 18 years. Considering this, they predict that
75% of companies that are currently part of the
S&P 500 will have disappeared by 2027. Also, even
if they don’t disappear, it’s very likely that
they become a shell of their former self. In the
2000s, the companies that dominated the fortune
500 were GE, Exxon, Proctor & Gamble, DuPont,
and so on and so forth. While these companies are
still around, disruptors like Apple, Microsoft,
and Amazon have grown to become 10 times larger.
But, wait a minute companies like market giants of
the past like GE and Exxon weren’t tech giants,
so they had a tough time keeping up with tech.
Companies like Apple and Google should have
a far better shot at keeping up right? Well,
this is not exactly true either and the best
example of this is Cisco. During the dotcom
bubble, it wasn’t just speculative companies that
got bid up, but also the biggest tech companies
in the world. At the peak of the dotcom bubble,
Cisco became the world’s largest company boasting
a market cap of $500 billion. If we adjust for
inflation, that’s $823 billion today. Since then,
22 years have passed, yet Cisco is yet to put in
a new all-time high. In fact, it’s currently still
32% away from its dot-com peak, and that’s with
Cisco doing a bunch of stock buybacks and trying
to soften the downfall. If we just look at their
market cap, it’s currently less than $250 billion
meaning that the stock has to run over 100% just
to reach their peak market cap from 22 years ago,
and that’s not even accounting for inflation.
Cisco isn’t just a one-off exception either.
Other top 10 companies that never recovered
include Intel and AT&T. Who’s to say that Apple
isn’t the next Cisco? I mean have seen the last
4 generations of iPhones? Only time will tell,
but just keep in mind that going all-in on
tech giants may not be as safe as you think.
INDEX INVESTOR:
And finally, that brings us
to the index fund investor.
If you’re gonna constantly go all-in on every dip,
indices are definitely what you want to be buying,
but I suspect that most people who are FOMOing
into stocks aren’t FOMOing into index funds.
With that being said though, it’s not exactly
a good idea to FOMO into index funds either.
Take the Nasdaq for example. After the dotcom
bubble burst, the Nasdaq crashed a whopping 83%.
Keep in mind that the Nasdaq is a combination of
100 of the largest and most profitable companies
on the market. Yet, it was able to crash
83% within a few years, and it took a long
and drawn-out 17 years to return to the dot-com
peak. Many of you guys watching probably aren’t
even 17 years old. If you invested in the S&P
500 instead, you would’ve had a better time,
but not by much. First, you would’ve experienced
a 50% crash along with a 7 year-long wait to
return to all-time highs. Just when you think
things are finally going to go bullish again,
you’re hit with a 57% crash that takes you
to lower levels than the dotcom crash. And
it’s not till 13 years after your initial
investment that you finally start to make money.
So, as you can see, if you go all-in at the
wrong time, you could still easily be stuck
for well over a decade even with an index
fund. But, at least you can be sure that
index funds will recover sooner or later right?
Well, Michael Burry seems to think that index
funds are actually in some sort of crazy bubble
themselves due to the rise of passive investing,
and that index funds are doomed to crash and not
recover. But that’s a whole nother discussion.
COURSE OF ACTION:
So far, we’ve gone through several examples and
hypotheticals, but the lesson at the end of the
day is to just not FOMO into the market. Just
because the market dips 10 or 15 or 20% doesn’t
mean that you should bet the farm on an index or
any individual stock. This type of behavior is
what leads to people resenting the stock market
and missing the best buying opportunity of the
decade. By the time the stock market actually
bottoms, they’ve either stopped investing
or they ran out of serious capital a long time
ago because they just kept buying every dip.
So, what should you do instead? Well, this is
not financial advice, but the smartest course
of action in my opinion is simply a long-term
weighted dollar-cost averaging strategy.
Maybe every week, you invest $100 into the S&P
500. This way, regardless of what the market is
doing, you have at least some money going into the
market. This is extremely important because the
only risk that’s bigger than FOMOing in at the
top is the risk you’re taking by not investing
at all. Anyway, going back to the plan, if the
S&P 500 is down over 10% from its all-time high,
maybe you could cut back on spending and invest
$200 per week. And if it’s down over 20%,
maybe you could live on sticks and bones and
invest $300 a week and so on and so forth.
That’s just one example of what you could do,
but there are several great long-term strategies
that you can implement. It doesn’t really matter
which one you choose as long as you stick to it,
don’t let emotions alter your plans, and
most importantly don’t be deterministic
about anything as no investment is too big
to fall. But that’s just what I think. Have
you guys felt any FOMO in regards to the stock
market within the last two years? Comment that
down below. Also, drop a like this video helped
you realize how brutal the stock market can be.
And of course, consider checking out our
international channels to watch our videos
in other languages and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.